ever since people found out there were
other worlds out there
this question has been preying on their
minds
are these worlds suitable for life
scientists have discovered thousands of
planets beyond the boundaries of the
solar system but most of them are
completely different from the earth
still among the multitude of diverse
celestial bodies scattered across the
endless expanses of the universe there
are some that are as close to our home
planet in terms of their parameters as
appears possible they are warmed by the
rays of their closest star and there are
great amounts of liquid water to be
found in their surfaces it is still more
amazing to realize the fact that for
many years one of such worlds has been
hiding really close to us
before we set out on a space journey
beyond the boundaries of our system we
have to decide on the manner of
selecting a planet that resembles the
earth most from thousands of candidates
what should be the parameters of this
fascinating world and what should we
take into consideration first
it goes without saying that planets
favorable for the genesis and sustenance
of life have always posed considerable
interest to scientists
however it is no easy matter to single
out suitable celestial bodies among a
great number of those discovered by now
to have clear-cut selection criteria
scientists worked out the so-called
earth similarity index or esi for short
it is based on several principal
parameters
a planet's radius density and average
surface temperature
this combination makes it possible to
calculate the object's mass
approximately estimate its chemical
composition gravitational level whether
or not there is an atmosphere and if
there is analyze some of its
characteristics it also helps establish
if there is liquid water on the planet's
surface and other information
the standard of this index is the earth
with its parameters assumed as ideal and
did csi equaling one
based on the earth's similarity index
all the objects known to us
conventionally fall into three
categories
the first one is objects whose esi is
under 0.5
these are for the most part gas and dice
giants as well as extremely hot or on
the contrary cold objects
this is the category most of the solar
system planets and satellites fall into
it takes just one characteristic to
greatly exceed the maximum permissible
values for a celestial object to be
unfavorable for the genesis and
sustenance of life
let's take venus for instance
the radius and mass of the celestial
body are very close to those of the
earth however due to its close proximity
to the sun and a dense atmosphere its
surface temperature is extremely high
that is why in spite of a close
similarity to the earth on the face of
it venus's esi is not high
at just .44
of course there being any life on its
surface is totally out of the question
celestial objects whose esi is within
0.5 to 0.7 fall into the second category
these objects resemble our home planet
noticeably more
they're mostly rocky worlds with
relatively moderate temperatures but it
can also be ocean planets and even some
large satellites
incidentally a high earth similarity
index per se does not warrant favorable
conditions for life
for example quite often low mass planets
are incapable of retaining a dense
enough atmosphere
while their magnetic field is too weak
to protect the surface from lethally
dangerous radiation
other celestial bodies yet may happen to
be located too close to their parent
star and so get tidally locked of course
all these factors greatly reduce the
chances of life's genesis and sustenance
as for the third category it contains
celestial bodies with a high esi that is
over 0.7 all of these planets are beyond
the solar system according to estimates
the size of these worlds and the
conditions on their surfaces are
potentially close to those of the earth
among these planets there is one which
resembles ours most
and it lies just 12 and a half light
years away from the earth
this amazing world orbits teagarden's
star a small red dwarf discovered in
2003
this star is
1370 times dimmer than the sun
this means that it cannot be observed
with the naked eye even though it lies
quite close to the earth
the mass of this tiny star is roughly
nine percent that of the sun and its
radius is about five percent bigger than
that of jupiter
gravitational forces are barely strong
enough to maintain the thermonuclear
reaction in the star's interior
that is why the surface temperature is
just 2900
kelvin or roughly
2630 degrees celsius
as is the case for all red dwarfs
degarden's star's habitable zone is
comparatively narrow and located very
close to it back in 2019 two exoplanets
were detected in its system after
continuous observations of the star's
proper motion
interestingly one of them lies beyond
the star's habitable zone and the other
within
the outer planet dubbed t garden c
follows an almost ideal circular orbit
around the system's center with the
orbits radius 0.045 astronomical units
it is completed every 11 and a half days
it is presumably a rocky celestial body
with a mass 11 percent bigger than that
of the earth
its radius is estimated to be
approximately three and a half percent
bigger than that of our planet
unfortunately conditions on t garden
sea's surface are far from hospitable
due to the low luminosity of its parent
star the object enjoys 63 percent less
energy than what the earth receives from
the sun
as a result the planet's surface
temperature is gauged at 47 degrees
celsius below zero on average which is
too low for life sustenance at least in
the forms we know it
still the chance of there being vast
oceans of salty water concealed under a
thick layer of ice on t garden sea as is
the case with jupiter's satellites for
instance shouldn't be ruled out
as for the inner planet it is dubbed d
garden b
it is actually this planet that is the
most earth-like object of all those
discovered to date
its csi is 0.95
which is just 0.05 less than the
standard ideal value of our earth
this celestial body lies 0.025
astronomical units away from its star
and it takes it roughly 5 days to
complete a full orbit around it
by following a practically circular
orbit the exoplanet is constantly in its
star's habitable zone and it receives 15
percent more radiation from it than the
earth from the sun
according to some estimates t-garden b's
mass is just five percent more than that
of our planet
as for its radius it differs from that
of the earth by a minuscule ratio
which means that the gravitation value
is also quite close to what we're used
to on our home planet
this makes it logical to assume that the
inner makeup of the exoplanet is highly
likely to be similar to that of the
earth
there is a massive metallic core coated
in a thick layer of mold and silicate
mantle reckoned to be at the center of
the planet
the celestial object's outer part is
covered with a relatively thin crust of
solidified rocks
mathematical modeling shows that the
average temperature of t garden b is 28
degrees celsius which is 14 degrees more
than that of the earth
this means that conditions on its
surface allow the planet to halve and
retain a notion of liquid water
and the planet's temperature profile is
potentially favorable for most
microorganisms even though tea garden b
is quite massive and is capable of
retaining a comparatively dense
atmosphere the radial velocities method
which is used for exoplanets detection
is quite inadequate for obtaining any
information about the atmosphere's
composition but it should be born in
mind that a planet's temperature profile
directly depends on its atmosphere's
composition
for example a dense atmosphere with a
high percentage of methane and carbon
dioxide will cause a strong greenhouse
effect
dense clouds of water vapor meanwhile
will on the contrary reflect sun rays
which reduces temperatures
we should also remember that no matter
how optimistic the parameters of this
fascinating celestial body might appear
it is not entirely flawless
being in close proximity to its parent
star it seems that tea garden bee is
always facing it with one in the same
side which causes sharp temperature
differences between the day side and the
shadow side
as i've already mentioned teagarden's
star is a red dwarf
and this class demonstrates a tendency
to suddenly flare up the amplitude of
fluctuations in its luminosity may reach
30 percent
which greatly affects the planets
located close by
still the chances of tea garden bees
capability of sustaining life are high
biological creatures often demonstrate
incredible viability
and their ability to adapt can't but
amaze
for example the ocean could serve as
protection against lethal radiation and
sharp temperature fluctuations
its upper layer is potentially capable
of absorbing cosmic radiation
while its currents could dissipate
temperature contrasts
for all we know as time goes by
primitive organisms might evolve in the
warm depths saturated with energy and
microelements
just a tiny chance is sometimes enough
for life to develop into something
bigger
every year astronomers announced the
discovery of several dozen new
exoplanets
the number of new worlds discovered in
the past 20 years is hundreds of times
bigger than in the entire history of
observations
thanks to technological advancement
scientists constantly obtain new
instruments for our knowledge expansion
and one can't help feeling that very
soon
the long-awaited seeds of somalian life
will be detected in some corner of the
universe
[Music]
you